[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y este es nuestro recorrido
de hoy
comenzamos en honduras para hablar de
las elecciones presidenciales que ponen
en evidencia el difícil contexto que
atraviesa el país centroamericano
pobreza corrupción e inseguridad retos
para los que los candidatos no
presentaron propuestas claras
y visitamos la comunidad indígena gnöbe
buglé en panamá para conocer su demanda
de la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos en contra del estado por la
invasión de su territorio ancestral que
fue utilizado para construir un embalse
hidroeléctrico
y acompáñenme a recorrer varias ciudades
de nuestro continente en esta emisión
con las millones de mujeres que
invadieron las calles en el marco del
día mundial por la eliminación de la
violencia machista
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal las elecciones
presidenciales en honduras ninguno de
los 13 aspirantes a reemplazar a juan
orlando hernández mostró una propuesta
clara para hacer frente a los problemas
de este país del triángulo norte que
generan las masivas caravanas de
emigrantes hacia eeuu un país sumido en
una crisis política amenazado por la
inseguridad por los vínculos con el
narcotráfico y por la corrupción de sus
gobernantes y con más del 70 por ciento
de su población en la pobreza la
realidad del país centroamericano en el
informe de nuestra corresponsal en
tegucigalpa que me ha torres
la pobreza y la falta de empleo impacto
en el hogar del eri ramírez madre
soltera sus dos hijos mayores partieron
de forma ilegal a eeuu hace tres años
con la promesa de mejorar sus
condiciones de vida el mayor medio una
vez que han aguantado la pobreza ya que
no hallaban el trabajo
que no quería o sea que se iba a ir pues
me dijo para sacarme adelante y él me
dijo mami me dices lo primero que voy a
hacer al llegar a es mejorar su casa
alrededor de un millón de hondureños ha
emigrado en la última década el 90% ha
escogido eeuu como su principal destino
le di teme que sus otros hijos sigan los
pasos de sus hermanos
la familia sigue creciendo y las
necesidades aumentan entonces ellos son
es decirme que se van y para mí la
verdad eso me duele porque
según el fondo hondureño de la deuda
externa y desarrollo de honduras las
cifras de pobreza del país se ubican en
74 por ciento y la pobreza extrema en 54
por ciento
eleconomista ismael cepeda opina que
será un reto para el nuevo presidente
lidiar con estos números y detener el
éxodo lastimosamente
la migración se ha convertido en un
flujo constante y ya va más allá también
de un tema económico va un tema
psicológico de desesperanza donde la
falta de oportunidades en nuestro país
por eso creemos que el próximo gobierno
debe tener una mirada integral a un
problema estructural que se ha
convertido la migración los candidatos a
la presidencia sólo presentaron
programas sociales paliativos ninguna
propuesta contundente para mejorar la
crisis socioeconómica de los hondureños
y así evitar la salida de futuras
caravanas de inmigrantes
con más de 200.000 habitantes gnöbe
buglé es el territorio indígena más
poblado de panamá la construcción de una
hidroeléctrica les ha quitado cientos de
kilómetros de sus tierras lo que ha
desatado una serie de conflictos con el
gobierno central que en la última década
ha incluido enfrentamientos y desalojos
nuestro corresponsal en panamá oscar
sulbarán nos trae la historia
es una oración a la madre tierra en la
que convergen también su fe cristiana
su voz trata de alcanzar al río tabasará
inundado en 2016 se ha convertido en el
embalse de una hidroeléctrica un grupo
de noves y buglés se mantienen en sus
alrededores y aunque esta zona no es
parte del territorio comarcal de acuerdo
con la ley panameña ella clementina
pérez asegura que todo alrededor de
estas aguas es tierra sagrada hemos
nacido aquí y hemos vivido aquí hemos
crecido aquí este la tierra ancestral es
de nuestro originalidad de una iglesia
originaria nosotros no estamos de otro
mundo manolo y su familia si viven en
territorio indígena han sido afectados
por la inundación desde que el embalse
de la hidroeléctrica barro blanco se
puso en marcha en 2016 sin el
consentimiento del congreso indígena
gnöbe buglé la comunidad y todo lo que
vive aquí a lo largo de este embalse
antes podía ir en un momento a que el
agua y regresar caminando hoy no lo
podemos hacer
o nadando se tiraba y back helado y
venía hoy no se puede hacer si no hay un
bote una lancha un cayuco como lo llame
nadie puede cruzar para el ambientalista
manuel zárate el estudio de impacto
ambiental fue pobre no se evalúa el
efecto de la calidad del agua tampoco se
consideraron los efectos en la pesca ni
en la siembra además quedaron sumergidos
petroglifos y cementerios había el
problema social
comenzando por una cosa y voy a producir
electricidad
contigo al lado tu eres mi vida tu eres
mi parte tienes que comportarte de
manera a que me produzca agua porque yo
necesito el agua pero yo no te doy nada
si no te doy ni siquiera para
sostenimiento de la cuenca una denuncia
contra el estado panameño por parte de
los indígenas por violación de sus
derechos reposa en la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
mientras se obtiene una resolución legal
las consecuencias generadas por las
represas seguirán afectando a la comarca
y vamos a colombia porque se cumplieron
cinco años de la firma del acuerdo de
paz entre el gobierno encabezado en ese
momento por juan manuel santos y la
entonces guerrilla de las farc que puso
fin a más de 50 años de conflicto armado
el más largo de nuestro continente el
proceso ha tenido una difícil
implementación el ex presidente santos
dijo en 2016 que para este año 2021 no
quedarían minas antipersona en colombia
nuestros periodistas luís muñoz y aurora
by ut nos cuentan si esto se ha cumplido
cinco años después cuénteme don luís que
por acá que cómo encontrar un grupo de
excombatientes de las extintas farc ha
encontrado un artefacto
pero podemos decir que que puede ser una
una mina antipersonal un campesino les
había avisado de que en su predio podría
haber explosivos de la guerra y no le
subimos junto a sus compañeros juan
carlos prepara una barricada que reduzca
el daño medioambiental
después mediante una barra de acero van
a disparar contra el artefacto muy lejos
listo vámonos
acá para que no para evitar riesgos los
desminadores se esconden para todas la
unidades y tiene la fuego en un minuto
un riesgo donde una persona puede se
puede un animal se puede accidental lo
estamos quitando pues por eso estos
disparos son mejores que los que
hacíamos antes
fuego en el área
humanicemos es el resultado de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla de las farc de 2016 aunque su
operación no empezó hasta 2020 reciben
financiación del fondo europeo para la
paz y su actividad está monitoreada por
un más el servicio de acción contra las
minas de las naciones unidas tiene más
de 100 trabajadores y es la primera
organización de desminado del mundo
formada íntegramente por desminadores
firmantes de paz cada día se desplazan a
los remotos lugares que ocupaban cuando
eran combatientes de artefactos que
germán baranda es gerente de terreno en
las farc era comandante la
reincorporación trata de mantener las
estructuras anteriores con un fin muy
diferente fuimos un actor del conflicto
y que también colocamos minas hoy la
estamos retirando
la vuelta a la vida civil ha significado
una nueva oportunidad a la chica
cómo estás
[Música]
yo muy feliz en esta vida porque ya soy
una más con mi familia pero el impacto
del desminado también llega a las
comunidades en colombia cada día hay más
de una víctima por minas antipersonal
el área que se despejó el verdader ya
está volviendo a un resguardo de los
indígenas embera chamí apenas un mes
antes devolvieron el territorio libre de
minas podemos caminar en este es por
esta área es muy grato saber eso de
parte de ustedes que también agradecidos
y nosotros es también un desminado que
permite que los niños hoy puedan volver
a pisar los caminos de un futuro que
sueñan que sea de paz
el 25 de noviembre fue el día
internacional para la lucha por la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer desde méjico hasta santiago miles
salieron a las calles para pedir el fin
de la violencia machista que deja según
la cepal más de 4.000 fallecidas en 2020
miles marcharon por la avenida paseo de
la reforma de la ciudad de méxico para
demandar más acciones por parte del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
en contra de los feminicidios y las
desapariciones de mujeres el presidente
ha reiterado su compromiso con la
defensa de los derechos de ellas pero
algunos colectivos feministas consideran
que no ha tomado medidas suficientes en
2020 se registraron tres mil 957
asesinatos de mujeres en el país
norteamericano
recordarán a mi hermana brenda ella fue
asesinada por su expareja padre de su
hijo alexis tener y ella murió más bien
fue asesinada el día primero de octubre
y el día del marchamo no sólo por ella
sino por todas las mujeres que nos han
rematado en chile- las marchas de este
día estuvieron marcadas por los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales en las que el
ultraderechista josé antonio kast se
impuso con un discurso anti aborto y
anunciando que quiere eliminar el
ministerio de la mujer los colectivos
feministas llamaron a los ciudadanos a
unirse para que no en la segunda vuelta
prevista para el 19 de diciembre en la
que se enfrenta al izquierdista gabriel
boric en el país austral se cometieron
43 feminicidios en 2020 según cifras
oficiales no al fascismo no al fascismo
no retrocedamos a los años 70 73
porque hemos dado algo creo que hoy en
día tenemos un poco más de derechos
sobre nuestro cuerpo sobre nuestras
opiniones y aún así existe hoy en día la
violencia de género la violencia
obstétrica la violencia hacia la mujer y
las calles de bogotá también se llenaron
de mujeres las movilizaciones terminaron
en la plaza de bolívar el corazón de la
capital de colombia para pedir a las
autoridades locales políticas públicas
contra la violencia de género tan sólo
en bogotá entre enero y octubre de 2021
79 mujeres han sido asesinadas
bueno las diferentes violencias que el
estado sigue ejerciendo contra las
mujeres la violencia política la corte
sigue sin tomar una decisión para
eliminar el delito del aborto del código
penal la persecución judicial a julián a
una defensora derechos humanos la
procesaron por defender el derecho a la
protesta y todo por todas las mujeres
que siguen matando el patriarcado y que
el estado les sigue fallando con
impunidad y precisamente me despido en
colombia con esta versión de la canción
sin miedo un canto que se popularizó en
mexico entre los colectivos feministas y
las mujeres
al margen del día internacional de la
mujer para esta jornada por la
eliminación de la violencia contra
nosotras indígenas colombianas la
tomaron e hicieron su propia versión en
sus lenguas nativas
[Música]
primera y estado chivas h
y
y dicho igualaron
chipper oxidado
y qué avaricia más
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas en la producción estuvo
giovanni modelo sigan viendo más en
france 24
tristeza y gas
por ninguna mano
[Música]
sin vender
tucumán y con ella
[Música]